[Música]
el mundo está expectante ante el avance
ruso sobre quién es la capital ucraniana
que estuvo repeliendo ataques durante
toda la jornada del viernes desde varios
frentes mientras tanto ucrania y rusia
discute en lugar y fecha para iniciar
eventuales conversaciones
naciones unidas- aseguró que más de 50
mil ucranianos ya huyeron del país tras
la invasión de rusia y añadió que espera
flujos de entre 1 y 5 millones de
refugiados ucranianos la unión europea
por su parte anunció que los países
miembros se preparan para recibirlos
amnistía internacional denuncia
violaciones a los derechos humanos por
parte de las fuerzas de seguridad en
colombia en el marco de las protestas de
2021 las violaciones más graves habrían
tenido lugar en cali en la denominada
'operación silo en el 3 de mayo en donde
se habrían usado armas letales contra
manifestantes pacíficos
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 soy rodrigo sedano y es un
gusto acompañarlos el mundo está
expectante por el avance de las tropas
rusas sobre kiev que estuvo repeliendo
ataques durante todo el viernes desde
varios frentes por el norte en el
distrito de obeh lonski por el oeste
donde tomaron el aeropuerto de host omel
y avanzan por el distrito de fort cel y
desde el este donde los ucranianos
volaron un puente para evitar el paso de
los tanques que avanzan hacia el río
nipper
en nueva york se reunió el consejo de
seguridad de las naciones unidas que
finalmente no logró aprobar una
resolución sobre la agresión rusa de
ucrania precisamente por el voto de en
contra de la federación rusa que tiene
derecho de veto en las votaciones por su
estatus de miembro permanente en dicho
consejo
el resultado de la votación es el
siguiente
11 votos a favor y un voto en contra 3
abstenciones
la resolución no ha sido adoptada tras
el voto negativo de un miembro
permanente del consejo de seguridad
más tarde el secretario general de las
naciones unidas antonio gutiérrez habló
para informar que la onu aumentará las
operaciones humanitarias en ucrania y
recordó que la organización que preside
nació para terminar con la guerra un
propósito que no se logró el viernes
gutiérrez pidió a putin en el nombre de
la humanidad que acabe con esta guerra
united nations was born out of world las
naciones unidas- nacieron de la guerra
para terminar la guerra hoy ese objetivo
no se logró pero no debemos rendirnos
estoy más en efectiva y debemos darle a
la paz otra oportunidad los soldados
deben regresar a sus cuarteles
los líderes necesitan regresar el camino
del diálogo y la paz en peace
el jefe de asistencia humanitaria de
naciones unidas martin griffiths dijo
que se necesitarán más de mil millones
de dólares para las operaciones de ayuda
en ucrania durante los próximos tres
meses ya que cientos de miles de
personas están en movimiento después de
los ataques rusos
estamos preocupados por los reportes de
desplazamientos a medida que hombres
mujeres y niños huyen en búsqueda de
protección creo que es justo decir que
cientos de miles de personas se mueven
dentro de ucrania y fuera de ella en
este momento
un ex secretario general anunció 20
millones de dólares para un fondo
central de emergencias para ampliar la
respuesta inmediata los necesitamos
porque empezamos a darnos cuenta de la
escalada de las necesidades en estas
circunstancias extraordinarias que será
de las más altas bendis very very
explorer seconds anses les grands beat
of the heights
y naciones unidas aseguró que más de 50
mil ucranianos ya huyeron del país tras
la invasión de rusia y añadió que se
prepara para flujos de 1 hasta 5
millones de refugiados ucranianos unas
100.000 personas se han desplazado y
miles más intentan cruzar las fronteras
con los países vecinos también europea
ha anunciado la coordinación de los
países para la recepción de estas
personas marinas sardiña tiene los
detalles
mientras unos pasaron la noche en
refugios subterráneos
otros cargan sus pertenencias y se
apresuran resignados a abandonar ucrania
ante los ataques del ejército ruso en
diversos puntos del país como esta mujer
que se dirige en bicicleta a la frontera
húngara
tuvimos que dejar atrás todo el trabajo
nuestra vida es una sensación terrible
dejar tu casa ni te imaginas cómo me
siento ahora
una imagen que se repite de moldavia a
polonia los países centroeuropeos se
disponen a instalar puntos de recepción
de refugiados en sus fronteras a la
espera de una gran afluencia de
ucranianos que están intentando huir por
tierra en las últimas horas absorto
melián fútbol hasta 5 millones de
personas pueden huir de ucrania a otros
países si la situación se agrava se da
güi jaf según acnur más de 100 mil
personas se han desplazado de sus
hogares desde el inicio de la ofensiva
del kremlin sobre ucrania una amenaza
que afecta también a los menores de edad
como muchos de ustedes saben la
operación militar en ucrania ha supuesto
una amenaza inmediata para la vida y el
bienestar de los 75 millones de niño
pero no todos pueden salir el gobierno
ucraniano ha restringido el paso de sus
fronteras a los hombres de entre 18 y 60
años que deben tomar las armas para
luchar contra las tropas rusas las
estaciones de tren y bus las mujeres
abrazan entre lágrimas a sus hijos y
maridos quienes están sin disco como ya
se ha dicho
debido a la ley marcial todos los
militares obligados todos los hombres
deben luchar por el país por la paz para
evitar los ataques de las fuerzas
enemigas y para que todo esté bien
nosotros y los niños debemos salir de
ucrania
y
la comisión europea anunció que está
coordinando la ayuda de emergencia para
la acogida de refugiados y diversos
países occidentales han ofrecido visas
para los ucranianos
en este contexto y a fuerza de sanciones
europa busca afectar la economía rusa
eeuu reino unido y la unión europea
comenzaron a aplicar medidas contra
bancos y oligarcas rusos próximos al
kremlin conozcamos algunos de ellos en
el siguiente informe
ya estaba entre los oligarcas rusos
sancionados por washington y la unión
europea desde la anexión a crimea en
2014 arcadi rothenberg es cercano a
vladimir putin compañero de judo en su
juventud en san petesburgo ahora con su
hermano boris y su hijo y con quienes
han visto congelado sus activos por
reino unido también se les prohíbe
entrar a la isla son los típicos
multimillonarios que han construido sus
fortunas gracias al ascenso político de
vladimir putin han tomado
participaciones en la industria del gas
en instituciones bancarias y en el
sector de la construcción por ejemplo en
2015 los rothenberg ganaron el contrato
para construir el puente que une crimea
con rusia también estuvieron implicados
por los papeles de panamá entre otras
cosas por la gigantesca malversación de
fondos para la construcción de la villa
olímpica para los juegos olímpicos de
eso en 2014 él también apareció en esta
investigación
gennady timchenko cuya fortuna se estima
en casi 24 mil millones de dólares una
fortuna construida en el comercio del
petróleo antes de diversificarse en el
gas la petroquímica y las nuevas
tecnologías muy cercano a los círculos
empresariales franceses se dice que ha
financiado el palacio construido a las
orillas del mar negro para su amigo
putin ahora es el tercer oligarca ruso
en el punto de mira de londres
vamos a crear una nueva unidad dedicada
a la cleptocracia dentro de la agencia
nacional del crimen para perseguir la
evasión de sanciones y congelar los
activos rusos ocultos en reino unido- y
eso significa que los oligarcas de
londres no tendrán donde esconderse
londres ha sido señalado durante años
por permitir que muchos ciudadanos rusos
se establecieran en reino unido- cuyo
dinero de dudosa procedencia pasaba por
la city para ser blanqueado y luego re
invertido en todo el mundo especialmente
en propiedades en la riviera francesa o
en mónaco otros oligarcas rusos la
mayoría de los cuales surgieron tras la
caída de la unión soviética al hacerse
con empresas privadas también podrían
ser objeto de sanciones este es por
ejemplo el caso de roman abramovich que
a pesar de las informaciones
contradictorias se libra por el momento
de las medidas británicas el propietario
del club de fútbol chelsea está al
parecer en el punto de mira de las
autoridades europeas y estadounidenses
entretanto la otan anunció que ya ha
comenzado a desplegar a su fuerza de
respuesta en el flanco este de la
alianza se trata según su secretario
general jens stoltenberg de un
despliegue de miles de efectivos y
fuerzas tanto aéreas como marítimas el
anuncio llegó tras una videoconferencia
con los líderes de la alianza
stoltenberg alertó que los intereses de
rusia no se detienen en ucrania
ya están operando porque emociones
tenemos tropas aéreas y marítimas que
hacen parte de las personas y más
denotan que están operando desde
el bálticos al mediterráneo algunas son
fuerzas aéreas el componente aéreo de
las fuerzas respetan
y luego hay algunas de las tropas
terrestres
que muy bien hace unos cuantos días
porque hacen parte del elemento líder
que ya está listo está preso o de los
elementos que están en un nivel del
tiempo como es bajo estamos hablando de
10 si otros ya están operando porque
hemos incrementado nuestra presencia ya
varias ciudades del mundo fueron
escenario de manifestaciones en apoyo al
pueblo ucraniano sumido bajo los ataques
rusos muchos lanzaron un mensaje al
gobierno de vladímir putin y pidieron
que sus familiares puedan salir de
ucrania sanos y salvos juan pablo lo que
me tiene más detalles
las ciudades de europa áfrica asia
américa latina y oceanía se llenaron de
amarillo y azul de la bandera ucraniana
en londres en la sede del gobierno
británico se registró una manifestación
de más de un millar de personas pidiendo
que se detenga el avance militar de
rusia sobre ucrania
espero que no solo el reino unido sino
en todo el mundo que los líderes
democráticos se actúen ya el futuro de
europa se decide ahora en ucrania
el llamado que se replicó en otras
ciudades europeas en bruselas bélgica
los manifestantes alzaron su voz en
frente a la sede de la otan al tiempo
que en viena austria los ciudadanos
rechazaron la invasión rusa frente a la
sede de la organización para la
seguridad y la cooperación en europa
necesitamos sanciones más duras
simplemente necesitamos las sanciones
más duras que el mundo jamás haya visto
ucranianos que viven en macedonia del
norte bosnia y jordania anunciaron el
apoyo a su gobierno pidiendo ayuda para
los familiares que no han podido salir
del país
nos gustaría enviar un mensaje al
monstruo ruso que ocupó la tierra
ucraniana que quite sus manos de nuestra
tierra de nuestro pueblo porque somos
ucranianos somos un país independiente y
no somos rusos and sweet
we are nations
y aunque yo vi a una inmensa bandera de
ucrania se extendió en frente a la
embajada rusa en pretoria sudáfrica
acompañada con mensajes que decían que
pare la guerra de alacrán ya también las
afueras de las embajadas rusas en india
y siri lanka se llenaron de
manifestantes que pidieron el cese de
las operaciones militares y un retorno
seguro de las personas atrapadas al
suelo ucraniano la bandera ucraniana
también se ondeó en nueva zelanda
australia y taiwán en donde entre
lágrimas canciones y pancartas se hizo
un llamado a la protección de los
derechos humanos de los afectados en la
nación ex soviética
también en américa latina' se
registraron protestas contra la guerra
en ciudades como sao paulo y lima fueron
cientos las personas que pidieron paz
frente a la embajada rusa también en
buenos aires capital de argentina en
donde existe una de las mayores
comunidades de descendientes de
ucranianos en el continente nuestro
corresponsal natalio que soy no se
ampliaba a los detalles suena el himno
argentino aquí frente a la embajada rusa
en buenos aires esta es una
manifestación
pidiendo la paz la salida de rusia de
ucrania de la comunidad ucraniana en
argentina que es una comunidad de las
más grandes del mundo de la diáspora
ucraniana
familiares generalmente de personas que
llegaron en el siglo 19 en el siglo 20
descendientes especialmente en la
primera mitad del siglo 20 en un periodo
justamente en el que ucrania no era
independiente no era reconocido como un
estado lo fue nuevamente después de 1990
con la caída de la unión soviética y
aparece aquí ese recuerdo de los
antepasados de la persona habían llegado
aquí de cuando su país ucraniano era
independiente y reclaman entonces por la
salida de rusia de su territorio y por
la paz
[Aplausos]
vamos ahora está colombia porque la ong
amnistía internacional denunció
violaciones a los derechos humanos
cometidas por las fuerzas de seguridad
en el marco de las protestas
antigubernamentales que se generalizaron
en todo el país durante el denominado
paro nacional de 2021 luego de haber
reunido más de 200 materiales
audiovisuales amnistía afirma que en la
ciudad de cali el 3 de mayo tuvo lugar
la acción más violenta durante la
denominada como operación siloé allí las
fuerzas policiales habrían disparado
armas letales contra los manifestantes
pacíficos el organismo advierte que la
actuación represiva incluye además del
uso excesivo de la fuerza
desapariciones y violencia sexual
nuestra meticulosa reconstrucción
digital de los hechos de ciro e revela
como las fuerzas de seguridad
colombianas atacaron intencionalmente a
las personas que se manifestaban
pacíficamente con el fin de castigarles
herirles y asesinar les
y cerramos en eeuu en una intervención
desde la casa blanca al presidente joe
biden confirmó la nominación de kentucky
brawn jackson como jueza de la corte
suprema haciendo elogio de su
experiencia desde ser confirmada por el
senado se convertiría en la primera
afroestadounidense en la corte y hasta
aquí este informativo sigan con nosotros
[Música]